welcome to this video with 25 minute 10
second increment again some rapid chess
playing dress from the UK that's pretty
large rating gap yeah playing a somewhat
unusual time for me and it's not making
a move okay I mean you have some time in
25 minutes okay here we go hmm can I do
something that and not normally do I
mean I certainly can recently I've taken
interest in some Queens gambit with
black let's let's see what we get
but it's really taking this time okay so
let's go six
yeah this is in fact a decision I mean
usually they play quicker but Bishop f4
that's not a very common way to play
this it's a very early bishop f11 now a
problem with this kind of move it can be
true we have to fold actually that can
be two issues with this one is that this
is a move not related to the sea for
porn so it doesn't help in recapturing
that pawn if black decides to take it um
and in some cases after Bishop b4 93 the
bishop is not really well placed there
okay wait cannot it's not really a
mistake or anything it's just a bit a
bit uncommon okay if I take three four
you can of course play maybe just queen
a 496 Knight f3
quinte 593 Bishop before it's a bit
wacky but interesting context is 70 it's
not a big deal if I go Knight f6 on
something I can still take on d5 which
hmm doesn't feel so great I can also
just check him on before that is an idea
actually after Knight c3 then kept
shauncy form and try to keep that porn
queen a forecheck knight c6 III 25
something like that okay let's so let's
do it check so we have a have a sorry a
completely unexplored position early on
okay I mean like d2d takes e4 looks
entirely wrong also taking into account
that I'm immediately threatening the
default prawn yeah 93 I mean you can
probably play Bishop d2 without being in
trouble but it doesn't really feel like
the move to play after having gone numb
we should be for check
having gone Bishop f4 and then going
back I mean I was irritated by a server
message that there will be a server
reboot in 30 minutes this is retaining
so I'm speeding up a little bit I don't
want any adjournment iam I will be
tricky anyway to finish in time ICC has
those server reboots once in a while the
IDC for was planned anyway on Queen a4
check i have 96 and yeah that's possible
but i can take before here i can take
the form
yeah I think I will that's really no
reason not to grab the big Center pond I
mean it hits against I really can just
take it for no no repercussions but it's
very important thing to him to remember
that when you are when you check if you
can grab a pawn in the opening it's it's
a huge difference if you can grab a
center pawn or um important than the
wing the beep on the ape on those pawns
are not very relevant for central
control however sent upon most likely is
relevant for central control and this is
such such importance that if they really
give you sent upon and you don't really
see something bad happening to you
should very very strongly consider to
take that pawn that's a really a big
difference taking an a pawn or something
hmm now that's quite often really not
worth it but if you can grab the pawn a
pawn yeah something like that it's some
something that should be heavily
considered so what is he doing now one
issue is that he cannot take on c4 due
to the pin with the bishop okay so he's
doing what exactly I can take be to
actually that sir that's nothing wrong
with that he cannot go rook be one yeah
so let's take them that will be a that
would be a quick disaster I've got c3
coming up
yeah whoo q1 assume the only move that
comes to mind and then c 3 oh my god
yeah that's not going to end well
I don't think I mean okay giving me
deform wasn't a great idea in the first
place but if he M started to develop
stuff that would still be a play instead
of Queenie to some normal move maybe
even now Knight f3 really giving me a
form o and maybe I believe now taking
won't be true then it's not a great idea
yeah I'm still going c3 there is some
nothing stopping me from doing that
Jeff dd2 is threatened to be taken with
check and on a night move there see to
check winning the Queen
yeah so that server reboot going to
terminate my game that's good news yeah
maybe they do it regularly at that time
that's that's very there is some
likelihood of that I'm playing early in
the morning German time and this is in
the middle of the night server time so
as some likelihood that this is that
normal time if they need need one that
they will do it at that time of day
now please don't let the clock run down
that would be decidedly slightly wrong
now you can give can check me an a4 b5
but that's really just one check
ya know how to have to do come true here
yeah its own okay now he's coming up and
now it's coming up with a move okay um
let's see how to do this is there
something simpler than taking probably
not so check let's take kingi to know
has to be played and then queen d for I
guess attacking Evil Queen a4 is no
problem as just nice to 60 no issue them
so to any anything that you can do
Bishop e3 I think I'll just take your
form it's probably the easiest okay yeah
this looks well coin if I check on c4
okay King f2 Bishop c5 Jackie can
actually escape 2 g-3 huh okay so what
is what is easiest here there should be
three years very likely his next move
hmm BB sixes no I can't I can't play
that actually it's not I could play be
64 Bishop basics but it should be three
still nothing it's not done not super
helpful okay then just absurd let's
develop stuff and protect that before
bishop
okay I'm anything that you can do while
I a trading Queens really okay um can I
do better than that I mean that's really
a na come on check
really playing playing this piece and
two points down in endgame okay you're
then let's play
yeah at least that's easy too easy to do
even though I mean absolutely everybody
is entitled to play on but it's a bit
pointless with like 20 something minutes
on the clock
push up five maybe instead helping yeah
not a lot but activating it a little bit
why not threatening Bishop d3 Bishop
them sorry rogue d3i a case doing that
I'm just taking on Rupert III that's
something better even okay I'm taking it
that's okay
yeah that's a second piece
check hmm it's really continuing this
right okay it's there some way to make
something out of this man may be a
bishop at night chica media
demonstrating that check yeah let's see
if I can get Bishop and night check made
out of this so that dumb maybe M can be
helpful to see I've done a video on that
but check
check so where we are getting down yeah
the first thing is if you check made
with bishop at night I only have eight
minutes because of the server reboot I
mean the games will not be M terminated
it's just that the games will be
terminated I'm sorry I have to check to
tell it correctly but there will be
adjourned so you need the King on the
edge of the board of course so I'm going
to go for that let's see i can only
check mate in the in the light squared
LightSquared corner and it's already
pretty close right i mean if we check
this I've kind of controlling the whole
BMB file here so it cannot really escape
um yeah I don't even need any any fancy
stuff like that famous w system it
should be possible without that so let's
see I think this should be right
so let's check some losing a tempo
Bishop retool all that check yet even is
that said are you working go back there
it's easier if you just do it from the
starting position of the w I guess so
what is sort of the quickest way it
really looks like it should be rather
quick from here check let's start with
that check it really should be okay no
what is the quickest way I wonder he's
already close to the corner
it should be ok so let me let me think
about it
to f5 should be okay at some someone's
III king of one is escaping it's not too
great so let's go here Bishop f5 I guess
or that's also good huh yeah that's also
good
yeah only in that corner it's possible
to meet five minutes left till server
reboot so um what was my plan here in
the first place this one taking away f1
taking away h3 and now it's made in X
marking you wanna check check
don't tell me you let the clock and how
no 20 minutes third server reboot don't
give me that checkmate no he did you
know what's funny I lost 5 rating points
by winning that game it's a weird
arithmetic right yeah it's in this in
the early still early days of the pool
there are some weird term mathematical
effects going on okay the server is
rebooting in four minutes I can just say
a couple of things about the opening
because the game essentially was over
after it yeah Bishop f4 is very early
the development of that Bishop is of
course quite common for example here
this nowadays is a main line of the
Queens gambit declined but this is very
early yeah black has not committed
anything here and especially checks on
like I did on before I might be
irritating as 93 it's not clear that in
this type of position the bishop is so
great on a form yeah I often get some
quick play with c59 f6 Queen a5 this
kind of thing and quite often you want
the bishop on g5 for a pin or on d 2 for
breaking that that pin detours far less
come no normally it's on g5 um so I mean
this is what you should do no not quite
sure what i play now I can actually even
consider to take it's an interesting
idea that I was thinking of during the
game and I'm just trying to keep that
pawn it's interesting is that a problem
now that actually is a problem that's a
double attack in effect yeah b5 is
probably a bit dicey yeah I don't think
that this is so great okay I'll take and
now we should just go III and play this
position one thing is that i had thought
about this move but it might be not so
good really and because of that Queen f3
g3 business it seems this is probably
almost the same thing and now i can play
97 why is that the case funny I
computers has equal which is crazy I'm a
piece down here I mean okay i understand
that black has some compensation but
full compensation Wow okay I only have
one minute left so yeah he went if
violet essentially gives away a pawn for
not much now he has to develop somehow
we should be too long I mean even this
is better change this and then continue
from them yeah but this is just using
instantly check check I could have
resigned here with a clear conscience
but to be continued and to check yeah
okay of course I can win easier than I
can't get at least like what check they
made them I made and check what I want
this can we do this quickly stop fish is
actually calculating a made from here
you check now you cannot see a maid in
xeo in the in the engine on a sec but
minus 50 isn't made ok guys thanks for
watching for the server reboots bye